one of one of the great reporters in the
state that badly needs more of them
well last week we told you that one of
the largest and oldest
banks in the country bank of america
founded by apg nini
is no longer really a bank it's not a
kind of intelligence agency
spying on its customers without telling
them turning
information over to the feds we obtained
proof that bank of america scanned
through its customers private financial
records back in january
and turned the information over to
federal investigators
once again without telling its customers
the bank was looking for people who did
among other things
rented hotel rooms in washington in
january
people who made purchases in january
in washington dc people who bought plane
tickets
what's the point of this well bank of
america when we asked them said they
wouldn't comment on communications with
law enforcement that was not reassuring
and told us the bank has quote
responsibilities under federal law to
comply with police inquiries
that's not technically true in fact what
they did may be illegal
but here's the interesting part since
our story aired last week bank of
america has not provided any
further explanation for the spying we
know they did
on their own customers for political
reasons
and as far as we know despite the fact
this is a big story
no politician in either party has
bothered to ask
bank of america so it's okay that one of
america's largest financial institutions
is now spying on people and by the way
bank of america may not be the only one
they're the only one we've caught so far
should you be concerned about any of
this
victor davis hanson is a fellow at the
hoover institutions thought about this
subject fairly deeply and joins us
tonight
professor thanks a lot for coming on
should we be worried about this that
bank of america is spying on its
customers
yeah because it suggests the quietude
might
reflect that there are other people
doing it more than we're aware of and
it's sort of also
disturbing because we always thought
that the corporation the financial
institution was wary
of the left and it wanted to
be bipartisan in its consumer base but
when it starts to help an investigation
of a particular ideological
or perceived ideology then it's kind of
scary remember
tim cook at apple during the 2015 san
bernardino shooting
the deceased shooter who killed 14
americans radical islamist
terrorists the fbi went to court to ask
apple to unlock his
his data on his iphone for the
investigations and they refused they
said we can't do that because we have to
reassure
our consumer base that their uh iphone
data is
uh sacrosanct and so we this is it's not
consistent that's what's also worrisome
do they pick some groups to spy on or
surveil
or turn over their private data and not
groups we need it we need to know that
and
i think people it's kind of scary tucker
because in this
huge octopus that we're facing now of
silicon valley traditional media social
media professional sports entertainment
hollywood we always thought the
corporation of the financial institution
was wary of surveillance or the left
because it was afraid of
you know the impairment of free market
capitalism but when you start to have
the corporate boardroom
or the financial institution giving the
impression
that it might have an ideological basis
for some of its investigations that's
pretty scary and it shows you that
wokeness is if that's the right term is
is everywhere now
everything i mean power and influence in
american society
this investigation is transparently
political of course
it they didn't conduct anything like
this when antifa
and black lives matter burned a dozen
cities this summer nothing like this
if apple were participating in this kind
of surveillance
of course you would have no privacy at
all that would be truly horrifying and
truly invasive why are no politicians
demanding that tim cook
explain whether or not apple is
cooperating with the department of
justice to spy on americans
i don't know that answer but i think
that politicians of both parties because
these mark these
five or six companies google apple
twitter facebook they have about six
trillion dollars in market
capitalization we've never seen such
money
uh aggregated in a 50 mile radius and
they use it quite promiscuously remember
mark zuckerberg 350 million
so it's not just that they're going to
give to one can a politician or one
candidate
they have the means to alter an election
by
getting out the vote or giving money to
government officials in a particular
precinct i think people are
are having an ad campaign or spending
100 helping to spend 100 million dollars
in joy i think people are
frightened of them and they also maybe
to give
tim cook the benefit of the doubt he's
on record
that apple would never do that because
he resisted
the demands of his own government that
was investigating a mass murder
and a radical islamist ideology and
would he be what tough on the fbi that
was
investigating mass murder and not so
tough
on people who uh you know went into the
capital
although there were five people killed
so i don't know the answer but i'm
i'm very worried because i think that
the average citizen looks around at this
panopticon and
every get use facebook do twitter
turn on uh the nba uh you know look at
your investments
uh look at your bank and it's all now
coalition remember this
time magazine's recent issue this secret
history of the shadow campaign where
they boasted about the power of this
collusionary effort it's really
i think people got to wake up it's
dangerous
it is dangerous richard it was hansen i
appreciate it thank you thank you